i like the larger amount i've said that
you know some of the republicans
disagree but i think i can convince them
to go along with that because i like the
larger number
i want to see people get money i want to
see
it wasn't their fault that this happened
it was china's fault
president trump a few moments ago
talking about the problem solvers caucus
bill or proposal i should say
a bipartisan group pushing for this new
coronavirus relief package
they're called problem solvers there's
democrats and republicans
joining us tonight the leaders of that
group democrat josh gothheimer of new
jersey and republican tom
reed of new york thank you both for
being here uh congressman gotham refers
to you
the white house is saying that nancy
pelosi is not moving
off of this bigger figure that the house
passed early on and that their
the negotiations seem stalled on that
front do you think that your bill
can move the ball well i think you heard
the speaker say just today that she
and senator schumer are eager to get
back to the table
and that we're not leaving town until we
get something done so i think both sides
are now appear to be eager
to get something done you know there's
been issues where they've been stuck now
for months
the american people want results and our
framework is just to provide
some to try to help get past some of the
hurdles with democrats and republicans
where they've been stuck and get folks
back to the table
and get something done so so i'm
optimistic but congressman
gothelmer speaker pelosi has not been a
proponent of your plan she says it's not
good enough
well i think every if you actually look
what's in our plan
uh all the priorities that the democrats
and all of us been pushing
are in the plan and uh it's it's a
shorter time frame to get us through the
inauguration
and and you know both sides i think have
no one said
they love everything that's kind of how
a deal gets done but the key is just to
get folks back to the table
and what we we all hear back home right
as you might imagine i know tom the same
way is
from families to small businesses to our
local governments they're just
dying for help here because the crisis
has affected jobs affect the economy
they just want us to get something done
and it's unconscionable for us to go
home without a deal yeah
let me put up on the screen what you
have in this in this bill and
as it's proposed it's roughly 1.53
trillion dollars
kind of this blueprint the state and
local
on the list here 500 billion dollars
that's really the sticking point
for many republicans and the white house
here is chief of staff mark meadows
talking about your bill and where the
sticking point is
even in the problem solvers uh caucus
initiative it was some 500 billion but
there was a caveat there that was based
on
real revenue losses and that caveat
gives me hope that if we're willing to
look at real facts and real losses
uh that hopefully we can get to to
something that actually makes sense
so congressman reid what about that
caveat can you tie it to
cities and states that are not in a
financial position that they were before
covet absolutely that's what brought
people together on this issue
republicans and democrats and
this has been a sticking point state and
local but it is clear uh that state and
local governments
have been impacted uh by the covet 19
situation and
if you have the revenue loss based on
documented
uh actual revenue loss not projected not
multi-year projections
but actual revenue loss you can you can
find bipartisan agreement
and then the other component of state
and local expenses that brought people
together in our conversations democratic
republicans was
actual expenses more like a fema
situation more like a natural disaster
where you had past and future coven 19
related
actual expenses where you had receipts
and you turned those into the federal
government then we stand with our local
communities
we stand with our state communities to
say we can reimburse those expenses
that type of good governance these are
american taxpayer dollars that we
need to be accountable to that type of
common sense type of approach brought
people together on this issue
common sense usually goes out the window
weeks before an election
it just happens because both sides want
to stay ground and make the other side
look bad
congressman gotheimer can you assure the
american public that something's going
to get done
before november 3rd i feel that we are
now
we're really thawing now and the
negotiations are going to i'm really
confident
get going again i think what everyone is
hearing back home which i think is
affecting what's happening here
is that folks need help and our small
businesses need help our schools need
help
we need more testing so all these pieces
are coming together
it's again not going to be everything
everybody wants but the bottom line is
it's going to really help
we got to get through the inauguration
here and that's going and that's the key
where you saw democrats and republicans
come together and and i'm optimistic
because we have to get something done
congressman reid there was some
suggestion on the democratic side that
they might get a better deal after the
election
president trump is saying he would call
people to the oval office
if a deal is imminent do you think one
can get done before election day it
needs to get done why would you put the
american people through that because you
want to wait for an election result
this has been four months of gridlock
you should not put
the american people in the middle of
this political race that
is why the problem solvers caucus is is
filled with members
that want to put country first the
american people first and i tell you the
silent majority of america
believes the way we do stop playing
politics with american lives we're in a
crisis we're in a pandemic we're in an
emergency it's time to lead
kudos to the problem solvers caucus
members like dean phillips like abigail
spamberger
like dusty johnson and anthony gonzalez
that led this charge out of the problem
service caucus with josh and i
to say enough is enough it's time to put
the american people well it is a good
remorse it is a good name
the chairman of the problem solvers
caucus we just all hope that you can
solve the problem we're going to get it
done
thank you gentlemen